علاج جديد للسكري يدخل السعوديه بعد
اعتماد هيئه الغذاء والدواء لابره مونجارو
او ما يعرف بيتيرز بيباتد كعلاج فعال
السكري من النوع الثاني يعملوا هذا العلاج
على خفض معدل السكر التراكمي وبدوره يؤدي
الى حمايه القلب والكل وفقا لاطباء تعد
الاعراض الجانبيه للعلاج الجديد اقل من
تلك المصاحبه لابره الاوزمبيك الشهيره
ويعمل العلاج على المساعده في نزول الوزن
من خلال تقليل الشهيه وزياده الشعور
بالشبع لكنه ليس مخصصا لانزال الوزن وفق
تاكيدات هيئه الغذاء والدواء تصل نسبه
نزول الوزن الى نحو
22.5% عند اخذ الجرعه بمقدارها الاعلى
في استديوهاتنا من الرياض ينضم لنا
الدكتور عاصم القرشي استشاري امراض السكري
حياك الله دكتور حياك الله استاذ خالد
ممتاز خلينا ناخذ فكره وعرفنا على هذه
الابره هل هي لعلاج السكري ولا لعلاج
السمنه او لهما جميعا يعني نبغى ناخذ فكره
عنها بشكل عباره عن علاج للسكري يؤخذ مره
واحده في الاسبوع عباره عن ابرات وقد تحت
الجلد
الجديد في ان الجديد فيها انها عباره عن
هرمونين جي ال بي 1 اللي هو كان مستخدم
سابقا في الاوزومبيك
والفكتوز سابقا والان بدا اضافوا له
الهرمون الجي اي بي وهو الثوره الان في في
هذا العلاج
نتائج لهذا العلاج المنجاره اثبتت انخفاض
في معدل السكر التراكمي لمرضى السكري
وايضا نزول كبير في الوزن العلاج الان في
نهايه الغذاء والدواء السعوديه كعلاج
للسكري في خفض الوزن في خفض السكري من من
مرضى السكري يمكن ان يستخدمه ويستفيد منه
مرضى السكري بشكل عام ينقسمون الى نوع
الاول والنوع الثاني غير الانواع الاخرى
فهو مخصص للنوع الثاني من السكري دائما
اللي يعانون من زياده في الوزن فهو فعال
لهم اول شيء ينزل الوزن ثاني شيء يقلل من
شهيتهم للاكل وبذلك ينقص السكر التراكمي
بشكل فعال فهو ينقص السكر التراكمي بنسبه
2.3% كاحد اقصى في اعلى جرعاته يعني
معناته هذا بس للناس اللي عندهم ارتفاع في
مستوى السكر اللي عندهم هبوط ما ياخذونهم
هبوط يحتاج علاج ونعرف سبب الهبوط
يتسد الشهيه تماما
وتضعف الشهيه هيا تضعف الشهيه لدرجه انه
مراحل ان الواحد يقول ما ما يحب ياكل خاصه
في بدايته ولذلك هي تؤخذ على تدريجي جرعات
تدريجيه لاعراضها الجانبيه تاخذها على مدى
كم دكتور هذه الجرعات تبدا استخدامها من
الجرعه اثنين ونصف بدايه تدريجيه واود ان
انوه المرضى الكثير قاعدين يستخدمون
العلاج الاوزمبيك اللي هو السمك
ليس لا نصحهم انهم يحولون على المنجار
وبجرعاته العاليه ولكن ننصحهم انهم حتى لو
كانوا ياخذون جرعات عاليه من الاوزومبيك
يبداون من جاره من الجرعات الاقل ويبداون
تدريجيا ويصل الى كم الجرعه
وهي الجرعه الاعلى وهي ذات الفائده الاعلى
الفائده الاعلى بمعنى ايش انه تزيل هذا
المرض تماما وتخفف من الاعلى بانزال الوزن
طبعا الاكبر مسبب لارتفاعات السكر وهي
مقاومه الانسولين النوع الثاني مع انزال
الوزن تخف مقاومه الانسولين وبذلك احنا
ننقص السكر عندنا التراكمي
ويخف السكر بشكل كثير
فمتى نقول السكر راح من المريض واذا هو لا
زال على العلاج اذا قطع العلاج راح يرجع
السكر فنقول انه المريض الازال عنده سكر
بما انه هو على العلاج في ناس بعض الاطباء
اتكلموا عن اعراض جانبيه يعني وحذروا منها
ويمكن قرات بعض الاطباء يتكلموا عن هذا
الموضوع في وسائل التواصل ثوره كبيره
انه تصيب بالام في المعده انه انه تسد
الشهيه تماما يتحدث عن مشاكل قد تصل او
تتسبب في اورام بالبنكرياس او في الغده
الدرقيه وحتى انه هيئه الغذاء والدواء
الامريكيه في في في النشره المربع الاسود
وضعت تحذير عالي الخطوره
لهذا وهذه
طبعا هذه هذه المضاعفات ليست توليده
اللحظه في هذه
العلاجات هايدا للمنجار ولكن هي من مصاحبه
من بدايه الفكتوزا جي ال بي ون ثوره ثوره
الجيل بي 1 ودخولها الى الاسواق
وجدوا في التجارب ان المرضى الذين لديهم
اورام في الغده الدرقيه
هم معرضين انه لهذه الموجود عندهم او
موجود عندهم تاريخ مرضي لهذه الاورام تزيد
نسبه الاصابه كما هي ايضا تسبب
بنسبه بسيطه
التهاب في البنكرياس لان لان
مستقبلاتها هي في خلايا خلايا البنكرياس
ما هي الطريقه الامثل للاستخدام هذه هي
عباره تؤخذ مره اسبوعيه ولازم تاخذ تحت
استشاره الطبيب لابد من استشاره ايوه
الابر تروح انت للصيدليه تقول انا مريض
الان بعد التنظيمات وزاره الصحه وهيئه
الغذاء والدواء اصلا المواطن لا يستطيع ان
ياخذها بدون وصفه طبيه فالوصفه الطبيه
ضروريه وهي وهي مصرحه لمرضى السكر النوع
الثاني فقط وليست مصرحه في السعوديه لمرضى
السمنه هو انا اخذها بس ولا لابد اقوم
بنشاط ثاني في المقابل يعني
حتى استفيد من من النادي الجراه كمراح
علاج السكر علاج السكر بدايه نقول للمريض
اول شيء نبدا بالحميه وبالنشاط الرياضي
وتغيير السلوك الحياه لسلوك صحي وبعد كذا
نبدا العلاج منظم السكر وبعدين نبدا
علاجات الجيل بي ون والجي اي بي وان يعني
هذا
الطعام يقلل
وجبات خفيفه
في ساعات معينه يعني
كيف تشتغل هي تتحفز من افراز الانسولين
تقلل من افراز الجلوك ويرفع السكر تقلل من
من عمليه الهضم وهذا ما يقلل من السكر بعد
الوجبات
وهي ايضا
تلعب في مركز الدماغ في تقليل الشهيه
فلذلك الانسان يشعر بضعف الشهيه وما ياكله
يسبب ممكن الم في المعده اللي هي مساله
انه ما ياكل مثلا
من قائمه او الكريتنز هي تلعب فيها
هرمونات
الهضمتي وتقليل تقليل خروج الطعام من
المعده الى الامعاء بعض الدكاتره تحدثوا
عن لابد ايضا بالتوازي من شرب المياه
بكثره صحيح
صحيحته فينسى يشرب المياه فنقول للمريض
دائما اشرب مويه بكثره عشان ما تتوفر عندك
ما تصير لك مشاكل من جفاف في المياه تنصح
دكتور المرضى اللي يجون عندك باستخدام هذه
الابره هي طبعا ثوره في عالم السكري الناس
اللي ما عندهم مضاعفات واللي نسمح نعطيهم
اللي ما نسمح نعطيهم سكر النوع الاول
فننتبه ان سكر النوع الاول والحوامل
الاطفال اقل من 18 سنه الناس اللي عندهم
تاريخ اكثر من 65 سنه لانه التجارب
عليهم التجارب فانصح فيها لانها ثوره في
العلاج ولكن انصح فيها بشكل تدريجي وان
شاء الله باذن الله تنزل السعوديه قريب هي
نفس
حتى في اعلى جرعاتها الوقاف يتنزل حتى 15%
تنزل حتى 22%
اسعارها انه علاج علاج جديد نزل في موقعيه
الغذاء والدواء 1261 ريال ولكن مقارنه
بدول الخليج بدور الخليج
فانا اشوف انه سعره في السعوديه مقارنه
بغير وافضل ولكن بشكل عام هو سعره اغلى من
الاوزون
ريال فلذلك ولكن كفائده وكثوره في في نعلم
السكري انا اشوفه علاج جدا ممتاز واللي
موسمين وعنده سكر اثنين يعني هذا احنا
دائما في في السعوديه نتبع ما تقول هيئه
الغذاء والدواء السعوديه فهيئه الغذاء
والدواء صرحت له فقط لمرضى السكري